today I'm signing an executive order
encouraging police departments
nationwide to adopt the highest
professional standards to serve their
communities these standards will be as
high and as strong as there is on earth
what's needed now is not more stoking of
fear and division we need to bring law
enforcement and communities closer
together not to drive them apart much
much too little and does not go far
enough I think that what we've got to do
is attack this culture that all of us
know exists
this is institutional President Trump
and the House Majority Whip on this show
earlier talking about the executive
order signed today in that executive
order on police reform it creates
credentialing certification and the best
practices for the use of force part of
that initiative the president wants to
ban the use of choke holds unless an
officer's life is in danger
addresses information sharing to track
officers who have repeated complaints
against them and offers federal
incentives to police departments to
deploy social service experts on issues
like mental health homelessness and
addiction Democrats many of them House
Speaker saying it's weak not enough you
heard from the House Majority Whip Van
Jones on another Channel said it's a
step in the right direction in progress
where are we let's bring in our panel
Jeff Mason White House correspondent for
Reuters
Molly Hemingway senior editor at The
Federalist and God Benson political
editor at townhall.com host of the guy
Benson show on Fox News Radio Molly let
me start with you I don't think that
President believes that that's the
be-all end-all on the executive order
obviously senator Tim Scott is moving
forward with legislation he's hoping to
get bipartisan support for that and
Democrats have their own yeah the
executive order lays out a number of
things that are appropriate for federal
executive action and you have bills
happening in the House and the Senate
that deal with this as well but I wonder
if too much of our response is political
and to federal policing is very local
and more than anything there's this huge
elephant in the room that nobody is
talking about if you want to
improve the situation for people growing
up in the United States today one of the
very biggest things you could do is
ensure that children are raised in homes
with their own married parents and we
have a crisis in this country with 40%
of children not being born to married
parents and if you're talking about
graduation from high school getting into
college having a career not getting in
altercations with police not being
incarcerated not being drug-addicted and
all these types of things this is one of
the most important things we could do
nobody seems to be talking about it
probably because it's very difficult to
talk about it but it's very important if
we actually care about children in this
country and improving their situation
Jeff obviously the political divide here
is as strong as far as what's happening
and how it's being interpreted but your
view from the White House perspective
about what they think is going to come
out of all of this well Brett I think
what they wanted to do today was have a
policy response of some kind even though
it's just an executive order it's not
legislation but some sort of a policy
response to address the unrest that has
been dotting this country and really
taking you know having so much such a
massive impact on this country over the
last couple weeks the president talked
at the beginning of his remarks today
about expressing or expressed his own
concern and condolences to the families
of victims of police of police violence
and then pivoted pretty quickly after
that though to discussion of law and
order and to said the more of the the
tougher rhetoric that has characterized
his response to this for the last couple
weeks so it it seemed like he was
looking for a little bit of a middle
ground the executive order as you
mentioned before does take a position on
banning chokeholds except when the
officers life is at risk that is an
issue that Democrats and Republicans on
the hill are not entirely aligned on but
in general he still gave a pretty
law-and-order themed speech today at the
rollout of this executive order
you mentioned the families meeting
behind closed doors and John Smith
talked about that earlier didn't really
open the door - it said they wanted it
to be a private thing however some of
the family members talked about it here
is i'm ann arbor e's mother about it i
was very very emotional throughout the
the whole conference he with he was very
compassionate he showed major concerns
for all families not just one family but
for all families I can say that if I'm
president Trump was very receiving he
listened and he addressed each and every
family accordingly so God did the
president in that speech obviously
behind closed doors according to that
mother toned things down in the speech
what did you think of it I think that he
did strike a bit of a new tone in the
sense that he was softer he was
acknowledging the pain that these
families have gone through because of
these various experiences and I think
it's just a human thing if you are face
to face with people who've lost someone
at the hands of the police and have them
sitting right in front of you that may
change not just your tone but also your
heart a little bit in the way that you
approach an issue and it's right he did
pivot back to law and order that is a
theme that he has sounded many times
over his adult life saying that we're
not going to defund the police and that
sort of thing but I think a few of these
steps that were taken were smart and now
we turn to Capitol Hill will the
Republicans and Democrats managed to
find a few things that they can agree on
and actually pass something or is this
going to become a political football to
motivate political bases with nothing
getting done before the election I know
where my money is right now but I hope
I'm being too cynical yeah
quickly Molly I want to get to this the
Department of Justice filing a lawsuit
civil complaint against John Bolton
saying simply put defendants defendant
struck a bargain with the United States
as a condition of his employment and one
of the most sensitive and important
national security positions in the
United States government now he wants to
renege on that bargain by unilaterally
deciding that a pre-publication review
process is complete and essentially
saying it should move forward what about
this the ACLU says it has no chance but
clearly they're going to try to block
this book well apart from
the legal case where there might be a
there might be legal problems with
publishing a book like this there's just
the matter of ethically advising a
president and then turning around and
publishing a book about those private
discussions and whatnot and this
happened to President Obama it's
happened to other presidents but it's
just unseemly for advisors who have this
sensitive information to just turn
around before an election and try and
publish a book I think we will see he's
already doing interviews about him when
we thank you paddle